no matter the movie Chris Evans always
seems to be having a good time something
made clear by the outtakes behind the
scenes footage and bloopers is left
behind here are some times when Evans
just couldn't keep it together while
shooting a scene editor right Scott
Pilgrim vs. the world is a triumph of
comedy and sci-fi and the whole thing
feels like a video game without coming
across as camp a to be with his dream
girl Ramona Flowers Scott must defeat a
seven evil exes including Lucas Leigh
a former skateboarder turned gravelly
voiced a macho movie actor white
enlisted actual action star Chris Evans
to play this fictional action star
although Evans is probably not as
aggressive frightening and toxic as
Lucas take for example this moment on
set when Evans are supposed to be
threatening scars and instilling deep
fear in the underdog that's kind of hard
to do when you keep losing your train of
thought and forgetting your dialogue and
more than pretty good that's not the lie
long before Chris Evans and Scarlett
Johansson joined the Avengers that
already worked together twice in the
2004 college heist film the perfect
score and the 2007 adaptation of the
best-selling novel The Nanny Diaries the
future Captain America played Hayden an
upper-crust Upper East Side Harvard
hottie love interest for Johansson's
Nanay the character might be cool and
calm but Evans certainly isn't he has a
tough time with wordy mouthfuls of
dialogue and as soon as you get any
closer to that building he won't be he
wound up blaming his troubles on loud
noises outside of the cameras for you as
well as the fact that there were half a
dozen people running straight at him
solid excuses two most powerful objects
in comic-book law have to be me or Nia
Thor's mighty hammer and Captain
America's nine bombable shield
as seen throughout hundreds of comic
books and almost as many Marvel
Cinematic Universe movies cap shield
gives me onea a run for its money its
unique steel and vibranium composition
allows it to absorb impact and energy
alike if Captain America ducks behind it
under it or over it he can keep himself
safe from pretty much anything in the
universe this blooper captured on the
set of Captain America the Winter
Soldier shockingly revealed the only
thing so powerful that not even as
impeccable weapon and piece of
protective gear can make it bend to its
well a door
[Music]
that shield is just a prop and it
doesn't give Evans the oomph he needs to
bust down the big door Chris Evans just
can't seem to get a break
props wise did he accidentally offend
someone in the Marvel Studios prop
department did he skip acting with props
day in drama school or whatever reason
there are even more bloopers involving
props not cooperating with the guy who
just wants to play Captain America the
proper gravitas to his credit evans
gives it his all plan of attack
[Music]
this backpack is the greatest villain
Captain America has ever faced or ever
faced on screen it seems it wriggles its
way out of evans control over and over
again in spider-man homecoming evans
captain america makes a cameo appearance
starring in a short educational film
with a peter parker watches in school
it's an arrangement that makes sense
if any avenger is going to film a public
service announcement to remind all the
boys and girls out there to eat a
nutritious balanced lunch it's Captain
America he's a product of the 1940s when
such a shucks gee whiz kinds of PSAs
from movie serial and radio stars were
the norm of course this is all so
ridiculous that not even Evans can get
through it with a straight face I am
Captain America whether you're a student
or a soldier there's one thing that will
always give you an edge hot lunch
it's a super traumatic pivotal moment
and Avengers age of Ultron in a
commanding everybody pay attention tone
and with cohort Black Widow I decide
suited up ready for battle Captain
America boldly in tones Avengers but
then stops it's like he's waiting for a
dramatic musical stinger the audience is
waiting for an assemble to finish the
catchphrase but it never comes Avengers
[Music]
it would seem Evans was pausing for a
feds before delivering the classic line
he was probably just messing around for
fun because he quickly turns the moment
into a goof and the movie itself cuts to
the credits before the line finishes
acting is on the most physically taxing
or mentally draining job in the world
but it's not without its challenges
particularly when the job is acting in a
superhero movie playing Captain America
involves a lot of physicality for Evans
he's had to do one-on-one fight scenes
and tightly choreographed group fight
scenes pretended to operate vehicles
dangled from wires and taken on villains
at the front of a green screen
he also has to run a lot Captain America
is always running to dole out good
old-fashioned American justice to bad
guys in this take for a pulse-pounding
scene for Captain America the Winter
Soldier Captain Falcon quickly hoop it
up to where they need to be but in the
wrong direction this Avengers moment is
all about sheer chaos a climactic
apocalyptic battle rages resulting in
death and destruction these moments are
among the toughest for a film crew to
commit to celluloid as there are so many
moving parts involved in getting it just
right but also means the chance for
something to go wrong is much higher
than it is for a simple straightforward
scene in this instance one crystal the
other is the thing that goes wrong his
Captain America lays on the ground a leg
awkwardly hanging in the air above him
waiting a cue from co-star Chris
Hemsworth
for coming in but since sevens is the
one laying there in the foreground of
the shots he's the one who has to take
one for the team and he does it with a
laugh check out one of our newest videos
right here plus even more looper videos
but your favorite superheroes are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and to the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]